the six weeks the crew of this vast
vessel have been hell's two miles off
the Gibraltar coastline as the
international diplomatic battles raged
Iran amounting its tanker be returned
the US still insisting that shouldn't
happen it was therefore the Supreme
Court of Gibraltar to decide a grace one
should be allowed to haul up anchor and
set sail after being detained on
suspicion of shipping oil to Syria some
might say that once a state says on its
letterhead that it is not going to
provide the cargo of the grace one to an
EU sanctioned entity that state is not
going to be well regarded by the
international community if it breaches
an undertaking given in writing
Gibraltar insists those assurances mean
there are no grounds for continuing to
hold the vessel charges against her
captain and three crew were dropped it
was not the verdict the US had hoped for
after launching a last-minute legal
challenge to seize this vessel but it
provoked predictable jubilation from
Iran the country's foreign minister
Javad Zarif tweeting having failed to
accomplish its objectives through
economic terrorism including depriving
cancer patients of medicine the u.s.
attempted to abuse the legal system to
steal our property on the high seas this
piracy attempt is indicative of Trump
admins contempt for the law
the commandeering of the grace one by
Royal Marines on the 4th of July
exacerbated friction between Tehran and
the West and led to the retaliatory
seizure of a British flag tanker stana
in Peru which is still being held by
Iran there are hopes today's
developments could ease the path for
that vessel and its crew to be freed but
grace ones fate is not entirely certain
Gibraltar may have said she is free to
go but the u.s. is still pursuing legal
action to seize her for the last six
weeks Iran has accused your broader and
the UK of doing America's bidding but
America will now have to pursue its own
cause to take control of this now famous
vessel Michele Clifford sky news
Gibraltar